What's more f**k-able than a snowman?
Hi, my name is Grace Helbig. If you do not know, now you know. Your life is different now. Today-
we are doing exactly what the title of this video says.
When you think about the holidays,
what do you think of? Merriment, cheer, boning?
I Google image searched holiday lingerie,
and I found some very sexy holiday lingerie that I thought I could make
myself at home, with what I had on hand.
This is essentially "Will it 'Kini?"
but not at all. I challenged myself to recreate two holiday lingerie looks using only items
I have in my house currently.
Let's do it!
When I Google image search holiday lingerie a lot of like sexy Santa's and sexy Mrs.
Claus scenarios came up, and then I saw this girl. She's a-
sexy lingerie-
snowman.
Nothing says "f**k me" like 3D spheres of pure ice.
Let's make this look! So she's got basically a white mesh long-sleeve
bodysuit. That, I do not have. If you have that-
How was the rave? I'm gonna piecemeal this together.
I do have so many male wife beaters that haven't been worn yet.
My house is a treasure trove of trash.
So I'm gonna take a wife beater, and then cut it into a bodysuit and glue the cooter area together.
Let's start sizing. This is how-
fashion designers do it, but this can't happen in this area.
Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam.
There goes Goose. Yeah, just gonna let the cooter area dry there for a second.
Basic white body suit is done. It's long sleeve.
I don't have long sleeves, but I have
long socks. I still want to be able to use these after this,
so I'm not gonna glue them to this bodysuit.
Instead, I'm gonna use them as
beautiful tacky gloves. Next, we need those three buttons.
I have a bag of pom-poms, because what 32 year old woman doesn't have a bag of pom-poms?
So I'm gonna find a couple black pom-poms and hot glue them to the front of this.
There we go, we have our buttons.
Now, we need the green and red and white scarf with black fringe, so-
I'll just take another wife beater. Let's do that.
I hate that there-I'll take another white tank top.
Jeez.
This is about as wide as her scarf.
And this is nice because this is shining light on something that I don't think people talk about.
One of the sexiest accessories that you could wear in the bedroom is
(deep voice, slow motion) a scarf.
We're gonna hot glue these together.
Beauty is in the eye of the beholder.
Welcome back my doge, your owner is busy creating art and forwarding her career.
Base of scarf, done.
Now, let's draw some green and red stripes on this. Yeah, it's got some black fringe at the end of it.
I found just some black felt sheet.
This. Is. Lingerie.
Now our scarf has fringe.
Only on one side, don't show the backside. That's how it is normally in lingerie, anyway.
The last bit is the hat, which I just happen to have this laying around my house.
This is a
Fourth of July tiny hat, but I don't feel like covering it in
black fabric to make it look like the hat that she's wearing, because I might use this in the future.
And that's why I have so much sh*t laying around my house, so I'm gonna keep this hat the way it is.
So if you put all of these pieces that we have DIY-ed together. This is the final sexy snowman lingerie look.
('Deck the Halls' instrumental)
Ah-
Pretty f**king impressive, I know.
You couldn't tell the difference and I mean you saved like tens of dollars.
So, you're welcome. On to the next look.
So, the most popular image that comes up when I Google image search
holiday lingerie was this one.
(buzzer noise)
This looks so uncomfortable,
but God bless the girl modeling this for trying to make it work.
She's a gift to the world.
Regardless, we're gonna try and DIY our own version of this.
Here's what I'm using: this red bra that's totally fine, that I probably paid a decent amount of money for,
but I don't wear, cause I wear sports bras because I've given up.
If you have red satin ribbon, obviously that would be a much easier thing to use for this,
but I don't have that. I tried to find any red fabric, and I have two red aprons.
Let's just cut these aprons into some strips of red fabric that we can use to cover our landing strip.
No! Cut the longest parts first.
These aprons that I'm working with right now are a canvas-like material,
which unlike satin is not a material you ever probably want near your cooter, so that's fun.
I'm done, all right. Oh, whoa, this might be interesting.
How do you make a bow like that?
(indistinct whispering)
You're going to be a bow on my boobs whether you want to or not.
Perfect. Cut more strips, good old-fashioned hot glue them together.
Oh! Hotsy-totsy.
We're gonna measure it out.
Good, we're gonna glue this behind our bow. Oh, you can see it start to come together.
We're gonna let the hot glue set on our bow and then we are going to fixate it to our bra and tuck the back
piece behind our bra straps, so that the final sexy, lingerie
holiday ribbon wrap outfit looks like this.
('Up On the Housetop' instrumental)
Again, almost identical and because I used only items I have in my house, I saved literally
(deep voice, slow motion) $19.99
Wow, this has been a really successful DIY holiday lingerie video.
If you liked it, give it a thumbs up. Let me know if you want me to do more videos like this
before the end of the holiday season.
And do not forget to subscribe to this YouTube channel. I'm not necessarily
making videos Monday, Wednesday, and Friday this month.
Instead, I'm gonna try and make them at my leisure when I have ideas and feel excited
about something. I'm going to try and
recalibrate and figure out exactly what my schedule will be in January,
so make sure you're subscribed anyway.
And hit that bell notification so that you know when I upload videos, cause right now
it's a little bit all over the place, but by January we will have it figured out, I hope. Other than that,
I don't know.
Be a bow, be a bow, be a goddamn bow.
You're embarrassing us.
Nailed it, who wants to f**k me?